algeria's national squad may not have
any big name stars
but they've pledged to up their
performance significantly in brazil with
the number of more experienced players
their bosnian coach vahid [ __ ] hodgich
has drawn mostly on foreign-born talent
who play for european clubs their
strength will not be as individual stars
but as a working unit
it's difficult to say what the key to
success is you need world-class players
of course
but i think more than anything our
chance is in playing as a team
football has a huge fan following in
algeria
after the team qualified for the world
cup late last year
there were nationwide celebrations it
was only the fourth time ever that
algeria had got through to the world cup
finals
and hundreds of thousands partied in the
streets
soccer is the only opportunity for us to
express positive emotions
and to relax it's a valve to release
some of the pressure we're under
there's nothing else for us to be happy
about
political rallies are banned in the
capital algiers and police often clamp
down heavily on descent
the country is plagued by corruption
president abd al-aziz bhutto flicker has
been in office for 15 years
despite repeated discoveries of oil and
gas the wealth has not filtered down to
the masses
disillusionment is widespread
many people in algeria are very poor
lots of young people don't have a
job and have loads of problems so they
really let rip in the stadium
it's a chance to be passionate about
something especially when the national
squad are on
algeria are in group h with russia
belgium and south korea
their stated goal is to advance past the
group stage
something algeria's never managed before
in the world cup